it's doctor
doctor
[Music]
dis respect
you're talking about the two times back
to back i
just don't play games to play games
i dominate if you want to be a champion
like me
we'll get through this okay and uh
[Music]
what the [ __ ] man can you really ban
doctor disrespect
isn't he the face of twitch there was no
way that they're going to
just ban him out of the blue it would
have to be something
pretty catastrophic as far as i'm
concerned
we didn't do anything to warrant a ban
let alone
how they went about banning us twitch um
has done similar things with other
streamers without giving a reason
as far as the secrecy around this i will
say that that is unusual
doctor disrespect has never shied away
from controversy
and you don't need to dig deep to find
those controversial clips either
like the time he walked into a bathroom
live on stream at e3
or the time he shared controversial
conspiracy theories or the time he
confessed to cheating on his wife on
stream
as you guys know i have a beautiful
family and a wife
and kid and
um i want to be transparent that i've
been unfaithful
but despite all of his transgressions
and questionable antics
or maybe because of them donk is as
beloved as he is vilified
at least of his numbers or anything to
go by his entire streamer persona
is built on the idea of an 80s movie
villain and
it comes with all the machismo necessary
to lead an imaginary pack of bad guys
you don't think i'm just
a two-time video game champion do you
doctor disrespect refers to his
followers as the champions club
join the champions club right now he
routinely rubs shoulders with
titans of the industry one of the games
i'm actually walking away from the
station i'm going to go get something to
eat
i'm going to come back when there's a
top 10 situation i'm going to clean up
the rest of the
rest of the survivors i mean if ninja is
one of them
and before a mysterious incident took it
all away
doc signed an eight-figure exclusive
streaming deal with twitch
okay i appreciate everyone watching
today in the backyard who is going to be
looking forward
we'll get through this champions club i
know it's a tough that's
life's weird right now all right
[Music]
we'll get through this okay and uh
that incident was a permanent ban from
twitch that doc received on june 26
2020 and it sent a shockwave through the
streaming community
streamers viewers everyone was left to
unravel the mystery on their own
either by watching doc's last stream
over and over again looking for clues or
combing through his wife's instagram or
just coming up with their own theories
what the this is way worse than i
thought it was going to be
yes i seen that dot cut man
yes no comment i don't know what
happened dude there's no way that would
be crazy
all the daca boats like we're gonna have
to remove them like the half that's
happened for
fmc emotes i don't know anything about
the doctors suspect [ __ ] i'm not gonna
sit here and jerk myself off we all try
and guess for three hours
how many people actually know because
it's the ones that are pretending that
they know
oh dude he did something really bad oh
my god i can't believe this
you guys don't know what i know oh shut
up
she's shut up dude just just just
tell us or shut your stupid [ __ ]
dumpster mouth dude
but even more puzzling was the fact that
doc said he had no idea why he got
banned
and adding even more fuel to the
conspiracy fire was twitch refunding dr
disrespect subscribers
something they almost never do so we had
to bring in some experts to help unravel
the mystery and explain
some of the context here's nathan
grayson a senior reporter at kotaku
basically what happened as i understand
it having spoken to like sources
in and around twitch is that the moment
the twitch found out what occurred
the people who were aware of it more or
less formed rank
around like a small select handful of
people at twitch
and so like only like maybe a small
double digit
number of people at twitch know what he
did people floated
all kinds of theories anything from it
being a major criminal transgression
to it being a bizarrely orchestrated pr
stunt
there is no [ __ ] way that this is a
publicity step
like let me just say that again there's
no [ __ ] way like to do
this at this time
in the social zeitgeist with the
movements that are happening now
for racial equality for
sexual equality um you know
everything for police brutality to do
that right now
would be the worst calculated
marketing ploy in recent memory
whatever the case was it seemed like it
was up to doctor disrespect himself to
break the silence and
explain what the hell was going on and
on july 16
2020 doctor disrespect broke that
silence by giving two interviews to the
press
here is noah smith who interviewed doc
for the washington post
was this something of a criminal nature
was this something that the public that
parents of kids should be aware of that
he was doing
um or that he was accused of doing it it
was just simply a business dispute that
neither side really wanted to give too
much information about because they
wanted to maximize
their um return or their position these
were the sorts of answers that we were
that i was looking to get it seemed like
we would
finally know what was going on except we
didn't
doc's careful measured responses never
really addressed the questions head on
leaving everybody in the dark once again
i've certainly done interviews like this
in the past some you know where somebody
in the public eye has been accused of
something even though he hasn't really
been accused of anything but where
somebody wants to respond
they want to tell their side of the
story so what was interesting about this
first of all is that he didn't really
tell his side of the story um and he
preferred to sort of let the rumors
fester and build on themselves
rather than addressing it directly and
it wasn't like doc was the only one
keeping things quiet
doc worked with plenty of companies
twitch amazon skybound a production
company he was working on a tv show with
and plenty of others
but none of them were coming out there
with the truth about why doc got banned
i reached out to twitch directly which
reached out to amazon directly all
through the official channels
none of whom wanted to comment you need
more people saying like yes this is it
yes these are the specific details of
what occurred this is the time frame so
on and so forth
um and until you can sort of corroborate
all of that
it's too risky considering just how
serious some of the rumors were
you'd think that doc would come out and
refute the worst of them at least
or that twitch would try to protect
themselves by revealing the truth
but on the day the interviews went live
all we got was a mysterious tweet from
the man himself
and the twitch link in his twitter bio
was changed to a link to his youtube
channel
just a few weeks later doc was back
streaming full time on youtube
and breaking over half a million viewers
for his first broadcast
we started 11 years ago here on youtube
and boy oh boy oh boy does it feel good
to be back
predictably doc was bombarded with
questions about the band
but equally predictably he just skirted
the issue
no communication before no reaching out
nothing boom done
today six months after the ban doc's
disappearance from twitch is one of the
internet's greatest unsolved mysteries
one that may take some more time to
unravel
even a few weeks after the ban happened
i saw a lot of people like
in you know the mentions of people who
were talking about dr disrespect
or in comments on videos and on streams
being like
it doesn't matter like get on with your
life you know move on already
and it's like yeah but it clearly does
matter if a giant company like twitch
whose main you know whose main goal
is to make a lot of money got rid of
one of their absolute biggest money
makers then
it matters we are going to find out the
truth is going to come out we are going
to learn what happened there are no
secrets this day and age
now when is that going to happen i'm
sure i don't know but the big picture
issue here isn't even necessarily the
ban itself
it's the lack of transparency from major
corporations we've come to rely on for
our entertainment needs
i think the other thing is you know a
lot of people who
um maybe initially kind of backed off
from dr disrespect were previously fans
and when you're a fan and you're
invested in somebody like that you don't
want it to turn out
that they were doing something bad or
wrong because you know the way the
fandom works online at this point is
that people tie their identities so
closely to these figures
that if they find out that someone has
done something bad or wrong then
any sort of reference to that feels to
them like they are being accused
guy beamed after disrespect he's going
to be fine you know with his money his
you know and his family and everything
like that
for now um assuming that this was
nothing of a criminal nature
but a lot of people are not you know and
they rely on these social media outlets
for their incomes and one day
they come along and change their rules
or say this is okay to say and this is
not
um and i think that's i think that's
something that people should really
consider whether or not
they're okay with if a streamer as big
as dr disrespect actually doesn't know
why he got banned
that sets a dangerous precedent for
smaller streamers who twitch could walk
from their platform
and even more concerning is that the
people who do actually know why doc
off band might be putting people in
harm's way by continuing to keep it a
secret
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages